more and more covet deaths in iran
official statistics say more than 100
000 have died
there's a shortage of everything
especially jabs
iranian researchers have developed their
own vaccine but production is nowhere
near meeting demand
u.s and british vaccines had been
rejected for political reasons
meanwhile the infection rate is surging
only the usa and india have higher rates
[Music]
this is your kovid 19 special on dw i'm
janel dumalaon it's not just a rising
infection rate and a slow vaccination
rollout creating an uphill battle for
iran there's another problem as well a
shortage of many treatments and even
basics such as oxygen tanks that are
critical for keeping kovid 19 patients
alive
hassan ahmadi is looking for liquid gold
that's what some iranians call what's
inside these bottles
oxygen
amadi scours factories across tehran so
he can supply hospitals with oxygen
[Music]
unfortunately there are more and more
people infected with the coronavirus who
need oxygen but there simply isn't
enough to go around and demand is
increasing every day
this company has a small stock
more and more often ahmadi is contacted
by people who are seriously ill with
covet 19.
the hospitals don't have room for them
but often ahmadi simply can't help
if i have to tell a sick person that we
don't have enough oxygen they panic
which of course is terrible for somebody
who is ill
hassan amadi hopes there will be enough
oxygen for everyone today
the infection rate in iran has remained
very high with tens of thousands of new
cases and hundreds of deaths each day
only about 10 percent of the population
are fully vaccinated the government says
that's because of import restrictions
due to u.s sanctions
but some iranians also see it as the
government's failure
initially they refused to import western
vaccines
adding to the desperation many medicines
are also in short supply
long queues outside pharmacies are a
frequent site in tehran as people
attempt to find medications for
relatives sick with covet 19.
i need to find medication for a relative
the hospital he's in doesn't have what
he needs i've been looking for it since
six in the morning
those responsible should really take
care of us once and for all so many
people are dying every day they need to
help us
ahmadi arrives at the home of a sick
person where he delivers a bottle of
oxygen
unfortunately today he doesn't have
enough for another family that's also in
need
i want to help everyone but often i feel
so powerless
it's a real mystery to me how those
people who can help and don't live with
it
takes an empty bottle with him
but he doesn't know if or when he'll be
able to fill it up with oxygen again
alex vatanka is the director of the iran
program at the middle east institute he
joins us from washington d.c welcome to
the program
we're talking about a health emergency
and economy plagued by sanctions and a
crisis of public confidence in the
government
what more can you tell us about the
roots of this current public health
crisis in iran
you know it's a crisis on multiple
levels one uh on the one set of problems
that you know ibrahim brazil the new
president has dealt with is the issue of
public trust
iranian public simply don't trust that
their government is doing everything
they can
to deal with the crisis that's number
one i don't know how ibraheem race is
going to be able to do things
differently than his predecessor hassan
rouhani since this crisis now is almost
two years old
but there you have it brian reyes has to
try something different and the obvious
one he can do is to
end quickly as possible iran's
international isolation
he needs to make compromises on on the
nuclear talks he needs to talk to the
likes of the united states countries
that have offered vaccines in the past
and for political reasons tehran decided
that it wasn't willing to take for
example american and british vaccines so
these are political decisions um it will
take time as the rest of the world is
discovering it will take time to deal
with this health crisis but in the case
of iran there are certain political
decisions that can be made in tehran
that will help move things forward
can you tell us more about why the
political leaders in iran turned down
western vaccines
well as i said this was a political
decision ayatollah khamenei simply said
there wasn't enough trust that the
americans and british might be up to
some mischief i couldn't trust
i mean i'm quoting uh harmony himself he
said if they're good at making vaccines
why don't they make it for themselves
why did they send it to us
the message basically was that they
might you know
tamper with the vaccine uh in some way
or another tried to hurt the health of
the iranian public so again it was a
pure political decision on harmony's
part there was no scientific or any
other kind of data to back up that
position and in fact he has had to walk
it back since then
now is it fair to say that the iranian
government's mismanagement of the
pandemic is mostly to blame
i think a good part of the
responsibility has to go with the
political leaders of the country i mean
yes the sanctions were there iran is
isolated in terms of its ability for
example to pay for things like vaccines
i mean if you don't have access to
banking system and iran does not then
it's hard to pay for some of these
imports so surely yes the sanctions
regime
has made life more difficult but then
you have these political decisions like
the one by ayatollah khamenei where he
comes out and says we're not trusting
the americans of the british we will
make our own vaccine and they've been
working on this vaccine for some time
now it's not
it's not being produced fast enough and
so again yes uh the the process to deal
with the vaccine cri with the covet
crisis
no doubt has had uh
the problem of being slowed because of
political decisions made by leaders into
iraq
speaking of political decisions the new
president is under fire even among his
supporters for refusing to lock down the
country for two weeks at the request of
the ministry of health and because of
the shortage of vaccines what's the
outlook there
president
is somebody who got the presidency on
the silver platter he does not have much
support at all i mean this presidency
was engineered for him now he's in the
presidential palace he has to prove
himself he has to prove his credentials
and clearly what he's aiming to do is to
deal with some of the the crisis that
are imminently hitting the country one
is the vaccine issue i don't think
ibrahim brazil has any quick solutions
but he's also out there trying to for
example restart the nuclear talks
there's hope that iran can have some of
the frozen iranian monies around the
world are you know sent back to iran if
there is some kind of a nuclear uh deal
uh so the hope is that ibrahim razi can
do something different and better than
his predecessor hassan rouhani uh to one
deal deal with the public anger but
reissie has also a long-term uh uh you
know ambition of giving himself if you
will a good name and create some sort of
a positive uh light around himself but
it's not going to be easy he's got
multiple challenges to deal with but
now he's in the presidential palace and
then he has no alternative but to try it
a complex set of factors there in iran
alex vachanka is the director of the
iran program at the middle east
institute thank you so much for your
analysis today
thank you
and now we come to that part of the show
dedicated to your questions here's our
correspondent derek williams
[Music]
mandates are divisive in some places do
they work or not what does the science
say
[Music]
few mitigation measures have been as
divisive during this pandemic as masks
if you remember back
to those dark days of fear in early 2020
when when borders were closing and and
country after country slammed into
lockdown down
the topic of masking up
and whether people should be doing it
and if so who exactly should be wearing
them
it was a mess and and after one and a
half years
of often contradictory messages and
policy reversals among health care
authorities
the topic has become hopelessly
politicized in a lot of places so
what does the evidence say well
i think that we're at a point now where
pretty much all experts worth the name
agree
that masks help limit covet 19
transmission and to be honest come on
with a respiratory disease that's
transmitted via droplets and aerosols
exhaled by the infected
that shouldn't come as a surprise
it's been a lot harder though to pin
down
exactly how much masks help but now a
new really massive randomized study
which is still going through peer review
i should mention
it appears to have provided some more
clarity um the researchers tracked
symptoms and antibody levels in around
340 000 bangladeshis in in rural parts
of that country
providing different types of masks to
one group and encouraging their use
while no interventions were made in the
other group the study was pretty complex
and it produced a lot of really
interesting results that i don't have
time to mention here but one key one
was that the authors said that surgical
masks in particular clearly helped to
prevent the development of disease in
villagers that got them and were
encouraged to use them um rates of
infection among those villagers were
around 10
lower
than in villages in the control group
where masks were worn much less now that
might not sound like much but it's it's
pretty significant and and the authors
also add
that 10 percent is a low ball number and
they expect
that mandated universal masking would
almost certainly drive transmission down
a lot more
[Music]
and before we let you go some vaccine
news cuba has become the first country
in the world to vaccinate children from
the age of two against covet 19 using
homegrown jabs not recognized by the
world health organization
the communist island of 11 million
people aims to inoculate all its
children before reopening schools that
have been mostly closed since march
2020.
you